I have a friend named Sammy who back in
the early 2000s wrote some code for his
MySpace page what the code did was
anyone who visited his page would have
his picture and the tag line that said
Sammy is my hero copied over to their
home page and that was a bit of fun for
a while but Sammy wanted more and so he
tweaked his code so that not only the
picture and the tag line were copied
over but also the code itself and now it
exploded in just nine hours he had
reached 480 accounts in 13 hours he was
up to 8800 and in just over 18 hours he
had hit a million accounts which was a
full 135th of all the accounts on
myspace at the time so in a panic he
tried to delete his page and when he was
successful he actually took down the
whole of myspace with it he was arrested
and convicted of computer hacking and
ordered not to touch a computer for the
next three years but I think what this
story really tells us is just how
connected we all are
imagine you have 44 friends and each one
of those friends has 44 friends who are
not also your friends and each of them
has an additional 44 friends each of
whom has 44 friends who again has 44
friends and they have 44 more then in a
chain of just six steps
you would be connected to 44 to the six
or seven point two six billion people
more than are alive on earth today and
we've contemplated how closely connected
we are since long before myspace even
existed back in 1929 a Hungarian author
and poet named freakish Corinth II wrote
a short story called Chains and in it
one of the characters challenges the
others to find another person on earth
that he cannot connect himself to
through fewer than five intermediaries
this is the origin of six degrees of
separation if the theory is correct it
means that you would be connected to the
Queen or Tom Cruise in just six steps
but they may be the easy ones what about
this shop owner or
the Mongolian sheep herder what the
theory really means that any two people
picked at random from anywhere on the
earth will be connected by just six
steps the idea remained just fiction
until in the 1960s a Harvard
psychologist Stanley Milgram attempted
to test it he called it the small world
experiment after that phenomenon where
you're at a party you meet a stranger
and you find out that you have a friend
in common and you remark oh it's such a
small world
what he did was he sent out 300 packages
to people both in Boston and in Nebraska
now what he wanted those people to do
was try to send their package to a
target person in Boston but they weren't
allowed to send it directly to him they
had to send it to someone they knew on a
first-name basis who they thought had a
better chance of knowing the target and
they could forward it on in the same way
now as you might expect most of the
packages never made it but 64 did and
the average path length was five point
two so now six degrees of separation had
experimental confirmation or did it if
you look more closely at Milgram sample
you find that of the 300 people 100 were
located in Boston the actual city where
the target lived another hundred were
stockbrokers which was the same
profession as the target so only 100
people lived in a different state and
had a different job and of them only 18
of their packages made it to the target
so we're talking about a sample size of
18 is all the evidence there was for six
degrees of separation so experimental
evidence was tough to come by but a
decade earlier a mathematician named
Paul Erdos
had tried to work out the theoretical
properties of networks like these but he
didn't have any information on the
structure of real social networks so he
decided to work on networks where the
connections between nodes were all
completely random and we can actually
simulate a network like this using
buttons and thread where we just connect
up the buttons at random what Adal found
is that when the number of links per
node is small the network is fragmented
pick up any button and few others will
come with it but once you exceed an
average of one connection per node the
behavior of the network changes
dramatically they almost all link up
forming a giant cluster
now if you pick up any button almost all
of the rest will come with it this
change happens rapidly and it resembles
a phase transition in physics you could
call this a small world network since
the path between any two buttons is
short
the thing about random networks is that
they are naturally small world networks
because you're just as likely to be
connected to someone here in Manila as
you are to someone in your own town but
obviously a random network doesn't
represent real life very well so what do
real world networks look like well for
that we need to go to the empirical data
in 1994 a couple of college kids
invented a game called six degrees of
Kevin Bacon in which you try to connect
any actor to Kevin Bacon through just
six steps through his co-stars now a
couple of sociology researchers got
access to their database of a quarter
million actors and they analyzed the
network and what they found was that it
was a small world network meaning
between any two actors there were only a
very small number of steps and that's
very similar to a random network
but unlike a random network the actor
network also showed a high degree of
clustering that is they often work
together in small groups so how do you
get both this grouping behavior a high
degree of clustering and the short
number of steps between any two actors
well to figure this out they looked at
two different extremes imagine a circle
of nodes now if you connect them at
random you get the same outcome as a
dodj short path between any two nodes
but little clustering now consider
connecting up the nodes only with their
nearest to neighbors on each side now
clustering is high but path lengths are
long for two nodes picked at random but
what if you take this set up and rewire
just a small number of connections
randomly what you find is that the path
link drops rapidly but clustering still
remains high so the key to modeling real
social networks is to have a lot of
clustering behavior that is your friends
are also friends with each other but
also to have a few random acquaintances
and the importance of those
acquaintances can't be overstated
there was a researcher named Granovetter
in the 1970s who published a paper
called the strength
of weak ties in which he points out you
are much more likely to get a job
through those random acquaintances than
through your close friends and if you
think about it that makes sense because
you and your close friends all know the
same people and have the same
information it's through the random
acquaintances that you can get
connections with people very far from
your social circle so you can find new
jobs new places to live and you can be
connected to the outside world so in
fact it is those random acquaintances
that make possible six degrees of
separation I don't know but I've tested
it and I think an XP has dropped based
on how many people have friended one
another on Facebook the friendship
circles are grown not that they're bosom
buddies but the people gave access -
that's the point right
and it's do you know this person who
then knows that so that I have access to
these other people so I'm told that it
is wrong that's not just the six degrees
weird owner or most fun I think Neil
deGrasse Tyson might be right in 2011
Facebook analyzed their data and they
found that 92% of their users were
connected through just five steps and
that number is decreasing over time the
concept of six degrees of separation has
fascinated people for nearly a century
and I think that's not only because of
how counterintuitive it is but also how
comforting it is to know how closely we
are all linked not in some kind of
abstract ill-defined way but through
hard scientific data just six handshakes
will connect you to anyone else on the
planet now I have a challenge for you in
the spirit of six degrees of separation
I want to try an experiment I want you
to try to get an email to me but you
can't send it directly to me unless you
know me so assuming you don't I want you
to send it to a friend of yours someone
you know on a first-name basis who you
think has a better chance of getting
that email to me if your email
eventually gets to me through a chain of
people I will send you a postcard in the
mail and I'll tally up if we were able
to get that done in six links or not
so let's try to do it and see if we can
connect the instructions are in the
description
this episode of veritasium was inspired
by the fine brothers Ben and Rafi fine
who are friends of mine so we are
connected through just one degree of
separation now they have a brand new TV
series launching on truTV it's called
the six degrees of everything and it's a
fast-paced comedic show that tries to
show us how six things that we don't
think are connected actually are it
involves sketch comedy and songs and
reality TV I'm really looking forward to
seeing how they are gonna do this so you
can check it out
Tuesdays at 9:30 or 8:30 central on
truTV I am so looking forward to it and
thank you to the fine brothers for
sponsoring this episode so I could check
out the science of networks